[Música]
con 43 millones de contagios américa es
el continente más afectado por el cob en
19 casi un millón de los 2 millones de
fallecidos en el mundo son americanos
eeuu ya superó los 25 millones de casos
ubicando a esta nación como la más
impactada por el virus
por segundo día consecutivo los
brasileños salieron a las calles para
rechazar la gestión del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro de la pandemia de kobe 19 la
nación registró en las últimas 24 horas
592 o luego fallecidos superando los 217
mil personas muertas y alcanzó su mayor
promedio de perdidas mortales diarias en
los últimos cinco meses
el líder de la mayoría demócrata en el
senado de eeuu shop summers dijo que el
segundo juicio político del ex
presidente de donald trump en el senado
será justo pero avanzará a un ritmo
relativamente rápido los líderes del
senado acordaron retrasar el juicio
político de trump dos semanas lo que le
da a la cámara más tiempo para
concentrarse en la agenda legislativa de
joe bailén tenemos análisis en esta
edición
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros entradas 24 serra blanco un
gusto saludarlos empezamos hablando de
la pandemia de kobe 19 porque ya son
casi 100 millones de personas las que se
han contagiado por esta enfermedad en el
mundo siendo américa el continente más
afectado según la organización mundial
de la salud desde principios de
noviembre la curva de nuevos contagios
va en ascenso en todo el continente
americano casi la mitad de los
fallecidos por la enfermedad en el
planeta son americanos eeuu superó hoy
los 25 millones de casos ubicando a esta
nación como la más impactada por el
virus revisamos la situación en
california con nuestra corresponsal en
san francisco susana mendoza
en california científicos confirman una
nueva variante del cob y sobre todo en
el norte de este estado en ciudades como
california y es que eso si los
científicos aseguran que todavía no
saben si esta variante es más letal o se
expande más rápidamente que el commit
normal pero eso sí confirman que un 25
por ciento de los casos detectados se
deben ya a esta nueva variante y es que
california también tiene otro triste
récord esta semana y es que es el estado
aquí en eeuu con el mayor número de
casos detectados más de tres millones de
personas con la mayoría de las ucis
colapsadas sobre todo en ciudades como
los ángeles
'israel prohibirá los vuelos dentro y
fuera del país a partir del lunes
durante una semana mientras
manifestantes en algunas comunidades
judías ultra ortodoxas se enfrentaron
con la policía por las medidas de
confinamiento para frenar la propagación
de coronavirus las fronteras del país se
han cerrado en gran medida a los
extranjeros durante la pandemia y solo
se permite la entrada a los israelíes el
país ha estado bajo un tercer
confinamiento desde el 27 de diciembre
los críticos dicen que el gobierno ha
manejado mal la crisis sin ninguna
estrategia clara a largo plazo
por segundo día consecutivo continúan
las manifestaciones en brasil en contra
del presidente ya ir bolsonaro este
domingo grupos de centroderecha
organizaron una caravana de automóviles
en sao paulo para pedir que el
mandatario sea sometido a un juicio
político con miras a su destitución en
el congreso por su gestión de la
pandemia de coronavirus ayer hubo
caravanas en más de 50 ciudades del
gigante sudamericano andreas vaya nos
trae todos los detalles en el siguiente
informe
desde temprano una larga caravana de
automóviles circuló por varias calles de
sao paulo los que una vez apoyaron al
presidente ya ir bolsonaro ahora piden
su destitución a diferencia de las
manifestaciones del sábado en que
destacaron las banderas rojas de los
partidos de izquierda en la protesta de
este domingo dominaron las de brasil con
las que marchan los seguidores del
mandatario varios miembros de
movimientos de centroderecha que hace
cinco años lideraron las protestas para
exigir la destitución de la entonces
presidenta dilma rousseff a la que el
congreso despojo del mando en 2016 le
piden ahora a este organismo el inicio
de un juicio para destituir a bolsonaro
tenemos psicópatas en el poder y ha
llegado el momento nadie quiere
soportarlo más no vamos a esperar a que
un millón de personas de nuestro pueblo
mueran para que la gente se levante hay
todas estas noticias falsas horribles
que están engañando a la gente y el
índice de desaprobación del presidente
es mayor que su aprobación reunimos
fuerzas tenemos que deshacernos de este
tipo brasil se hundirá la falta de un
plan de vacunación ha hecho que la tasa
de aprobación del gobierno de bolsonaro
baje en las encuestas a esto se suma un
reciente estudio de la universidad de
sao paulo y la ong conectas derechos
humanos el cual denuncia que existe una
estrategia promovida por el gobierno del
ultraderechista para propagar el joven
19 en brasil el estudio se basa en datos
de documentos oficiales vetos
presidenciales y advierte de una campaña
de desacreditación a las autoridades
sanitarias a través de información
recopilada en redes sociales y medios de
comunicación actualmente un poco más de
600.000 personas han recibido la primera
dosis de la vacuna contra el coronavirus
es decir el 0 2 por ciento de la
brasil con casi 210 millones de
habitantes es el tercer país en el mundo
con más casos de contagio y el segundo
después de eeuu con más muertes
superando los 217 mil fallecimientos
vamos ahora a eeuu donde el líder de la
mayoría en el senado chuck schumer dijo
que el segundo impeachment el
expresidente de donald trump en el
senado será justo pero avanzará a un
ritmo relativamente rápido según él
tiene mucho más trabajo por hacer los
líderes del senado acordaron el viernes
23 de enero retrasar el juicio político
de trump en dos semanas lo que le da a
la cámara más tiempo para concentrarse
en la agenda legislativa del presidente
demócratas de upyd ni confirmar a los
nominados al gabinete antes de pasar al
juicio político de trump la cámara de
representantes controlada por los
demócratas acusó a trump de incitar a la
insurrección del 6 de enero tras la toma
del capitolio
el juicio comenzará la semana del 8 de
febrero y como dije creo que será un
juicio justo pero avanzará relativamente
rápido no tomará mucho tiempo porque
tenemos muchas más
qué hacer pero al mismo tiempo será
justo quiero saludar en este momento a
carlos ha salvado abogado
constitucionalista y también analista
político abogado gracias por su tiempo y
por estar con nosotros en france 24 ya
mañana los demócratas llevarán el juicio
político al senado contará al ex
presidente de trump con la misma suerte
que tuvo en 2020 cuando fue absuelto por
el senado en su primer juicio político
bueno eso todavía no se sabe pero hay
una posibilidad que ahorita se va a
encontrar en un gran problema porque lo
que puede suceder en esta vez es que si
lo condenan de la acusación también
puedes pedir que no puedas regresar como
a tomar una oficina de confianza y eso
sería algo que tal vez hasta unos
republicanos están interesados para que
no vuelva en cuatro años a correr como
presidente así que eso la diferencia de
este en prisión de este juicio de la
otra la primera eso es lo que buscan
entonces los demócratas y algunos
republicanos que están en contra del
presidente de donald trump que busquen
específicamente con este segundo
impeachment
o qué es exactamente lo que buscan
porque mira la razón por cual a
removerlo de la oficina él ya se ha ido
él ya ha perdido se fue a no hay paz
pero no está en esta oficina ahorita así
que para qué vale este juicio bueno vale
para condenarlo de lo que había hecho
que era algo muy serio y también para el
punto de algunos republicanos que tal
vez van a estar de acuerdo es porque en
cuatro años cuando corren de nuevo para
la presidencia a él puede repartir el
partido republicano que quiero decir con
eso
por ejemplo mira los trompistas cogen
como republicanos pero sinceramente no
son republicanos es como casi lo que le
había sucedido al cliente a heller kring
2016 los que estaban atrás de bernie y
lo apoyaban a él lo que hicieron fue
quitándole votos
creen ver así que yo pienso que algunos
de estos republicanos tal vez están
pensando en esa forma que quieren ya a
terminar con el problema que ha causado
entra entre el partido el mismo partido
ahogados al órgano pero
si ya lo tengo que decir porque se nos
acaba el tiempo gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en esta emisión de
noticias el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón habló por teléfono con su
homólogo estadounidense joe biden en su
primera conversación ambos resaltaron la
determinación común de actuar en el
marco de la organización mundial de la
salud sobre todo en el apoyo a los
países más frágiles ante la pandemia y
se mostraron de acuerdo en el regreso de
eeuu al acuerdo de parís para que abra
una nueva etapa de acción para la
comunidad internacional en la lucha
contra el cambio climático con título
cofinancian de esta manera llegamos al
final del informativo continúa con
nosotros y buena noche
[Música]